good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of cabinets and without further
ado apologies for absence mr. Webb
apology from Council Barca right thank
you
disclosures of interest canceled
farewell Thank You chairman item 14 the
car park at Emily I did have a meeting
with a representative from the parish
council and indeed with the appropriate
officer of this council to discuss a way
forward that meeting took place in this
particular building I'd taken advice
from the monitoring officer and I'm
allowed to partake in the discussion and
indeed vote thank you sir yes Thank You
chairman item 8 I am the County Division
member for Kinnison but artifact my
voting on this particular right many to
the last meeting all agreed a great good
minutes done right item for Jen
right page 17 are those minutes
acceptable as well good thank you in
that case now item for general day to
protection regulation Thank You chairman
I am aware there are blue papers on this
particular topic and would advise if any
of the members wish to discuss on the
items in detail then it would need to be
moved to a closed session at the end of
the meeting do any members wish to
discuss any of the issues on the blue
purpose if there's no discussion on this
issue then presumably thank you Kevin as
I think there are aware the EU
regulation concerning data protection
came into force on the 25th of May 2018
there is a requirement by that date the
council has put into place the
appropriate policies to support the
regulation work has been done over the
past few months on creating these
policies which to involve the management
team ICT and the previous Data
Protection Officer and a great deal of
work by Matt Collins within the legal
team to ensure that the policies are
compliant I'd like to thank Matt for all
his work there the policies cover
everything from the use of response from
user responsibilities so to use of
Internet emails and retention policies
there could be cases in the future where
certain operating policies within the
document might up to be reviewed in
light of any changes to counsel working
practice
I did mention beginning the data
protection officer who has left both
counsels I say both counsels as this is
a joint appointment with work district
counsel we do have a temporary data
protection officer in Khost and
understand that interviews for a
permanent replacement took place last
week
and that announcement will be made this
week on her successor German I asked the
cabinet to approve this policy so he can
go forward to full council for adoption
thank you does this mean you wish to
address his counselor that the answer is
contained in paragraph 1.4 1.5 and 1.6
and this was on the advice of the head
of revenues and ICT and is aimed to
ensure that we have adequate protections
in place in respective cyber cyber
science I was going to say cybercrime
and any other criminal activity which
might be aimed at trying to destroy
undermine the council's information base
thank you happy councillor Morse
thank you so in that case the
recommendation on page 21 recommended to
Council we do that agree thank you
item five notice of motion corporate
priorities this season bit May so
picking up the first item about the
scheme for compensation for this
Southwest in relief Road this is not
actually an issue for the District
Council this is an issue for the County
Council and as I understand it the world
actually has to be built and each
operation before things can be
considered item two the Stratford town
trust there is we have 25,000 pounds
available for a thank you Thank You
councillor kettle if I go to item three
the playgrounds are routinely inspected
and there is a program of work about to
be put in place to deal with any issues
item four on the town centre again
pavements are actually a County Council
issue not a district council issue and
item five
I think he's not something we would wish
to do so
thank you well just to be technically
correct it used to have a general power
of wealthy and earthy local government
that mm but that's been superseded now
by the general power of competence under
the Localism at 2011 I think three four
and five nineteen one which is the
compensation for residents affected by
the southwesterly flowed so I've put
forward to mr. Weber mr. Buckland at the
outline of a possible scheme of
compensation I'd say I'm not Precious
about the particular scheme I'm really
looking for the principle of accepting
that we have a duty to help these people
as the motion says what matters is that
help is given to people who have to move
house and whose property values have
already been impacted
by the road so I'm not trying to replace
a scheme chairman that the council has
written to the residents about whereby
compensation is normally payable one
year after the road is completed and
opened I'm talking about an interim
measure it's totally unfair chairman
that people can lose thousands of pounds
because their house is blighted and
because they have to move so we are
looking for a temporary scheme to help
these limited people until the final
compensation scheme is available as I
say one year after the road is emptied
open I don't believe that those would be
forced to move before the final scheme
is introduced will be large numbers and
I don't suggest the district alone
should bear the cost of any temporary
scheme no Carla can play a big part in
possibly the County Council and of
course I hope any monies that we advance
to people could be offset against the
final compensation paper so it would be
eventually recovered Chapman from the
final scheme and one final point
chairman when the cabinet put forth its
spending plans for the two and a half
million for corporate priorities which
this is trying to address as their as at
the start of the year but forecast to be
8.3 million pounds the latest figures
show that actually those reserves when
knowing point 5 million pounds in other
words so I hope that the cabinet will
agree to look at schemes that could help
this limited number of people you know
we cannot use massive funds as an excuse
for refusing to help these people
I hope the cabinet West the office is to
examine this further to see what might
be practical and what could be done
thank you
yeah council more sent through some
details of net I came last week but I
haven't had the opportunity to review
that as yet had some some an you leave
commitments last week I think
reference to agenda item dealing with
the revenue I'll turn later on the
agenda to give you that position Thank
You chairman as the responsibility for
compensation in areas like this I
believe is the responsibility of the
County Council and the developer I'm
wondering where the councillor waters
councillor Fred Lee have actually put
forward this request to the County
Council at cabinet and at the fork at
the last full council I've not had any
feedback from that as yet sir chairman
that it has been raised with the
representative not been on sipping
unsympathetic to the problems of these
limited number of residents are facing
just a concern that's on this particular
item if this council was decided touchy
to this conversations you're talking
about where would it stop one of their
schemes would would actually be
considered by the the residents in
public as being equally viable schemes
and where would it end and that's a sort
of concern there I've got there is a due
process currently far wrong and they the
process to me this isn't the first time
compensation has been brought forward
for particular situations like this and
the fact that we've got money in the
reserves or not I don't think is
relevant to this particular argument but
I am just a little concerned that it's
effectively assigned blank check and
we've got to be as a care as a council
we've got to be careful with our funds
and extending any scheme from here on to
other part of the scheme would be first
of all to address the area which she
covered which i think is quite a limited
part of Ludington roto stands closed
it's not anybody who would be affected
by the relief Road but just those people
most affected whose houses are currently
blighted and the second point is that I
think we would need a very careful
definition of people who were being
forced to move in other words this is
not a general offer of compensation to
people whose houses are blighted it is
an all sort of temporary compensation to
people through whatever reason are being
forced to move house
it may be for medical grants they've got
to go into a care home it may be because
their jobs come to the other side of the
country and they've got to relocate
there it seems to me completely unfair
chairman that these people cannot get
any compensation have to accept the drop
in value of their property purely
because we've decided a builder with
relief Road near the houses again
chairman you I'm not asking at this
stage for blessing to be given to any
budget any money or any scheme what I'm
asking for is that the officers be
requested to examine the possibilities
organ a very difficult one but it's also
difficult in that we're talking about a
proposed route and design but we don't
actually have a committed route and
design yet so it is causing me some
concern that that it's certainly too
premature because there isn't an actual
route and design that has been agreed
and approved so I'm not quite sure why
this is the appropriate time to even be
looking at this
it's the appropriate time chairman
because the line that was drawn the map
of the core strategy has blighted
residence houses the value of their
houses has dropped know whether this
scheme ever comes to a fruition is
another matter entirely
but I do not think anybody around this
table can deny residents have had their
house families blighted by the possible
proposals that will come forward and
that is what I'm seeking to compensate
people for temporarily to recover it
eventually from the final scheme
councillor Richards is there any
evidence to support that assertion and
how do you measure that
loss there is evidence in that I had a
resident come to me whose house if we
look forward to how we evidence it one
of the nuts covered in the proposals or
suggestions I've made to the chief
officers typically a scheme like this
would work whereby the resident who was
forced to move and there would be some
fairly stringent requirements about who
was being forced to move it wouldn't be
just because they say I'd like to move
the resident could pick a severe job is
where the council would pick a chartered
surveyor each of whom would assess how
much the value of the property had been
affected by the blighting from the
relief road if those figures typically
were saved within 5% of each other you
would take an average of two figures
that's typically how schemes such as
this would work
can I just check on something with
councilor fragile a a similar proposal
you said was actually put to the cabinet
at County not in this detail but it will
be put in this detail it was raised as a
principle that compensation when major
infrastructure projects are proposed
there is attached to that and we should
be looking in principle a compensation
scheme that could be discussed at the
initial stages and well it would seem to
me in all honesty that the County
Council is the appropriate body to which
those kind of proposals should be pulled
you've already put them in an outline so
one would assume they could be followed
up in the same detail as you have
presented to us today that's absolutely
right but well I think what we're
looking for here is is probably a
three-way partnership you're looking at
the planning authority which is the
district you're looking the Highways
Authority which is the county and the
developer that should be actually
putting those proposals together part of
their remit would be to talk to the
County Council and Carla Holmes I mean
we did receive a communication but
haven't had the opportunity to review
that I think you've already determined
that we have no formal responsibility in
this area and therefore if you did want
to consider this it would you be doing
so knowingly we have correspondent with
the local residents affected already in
partnership with the County Council
explaining what the compensation
arrangements would be of course it's
entirely up to you whether you
today nothing - we can all say as you
know we've got a steering group set up
and I've chaired for the last year
looking at the LMA site as a whole and
ended southwest relief Road as part of
that and this proposal or certainly a
very similar propose would be input to
that and there was a commitment by that
steering group to continue to look at
this through the planning process and I
think that's the appropriate way to do
it's not something for council or the
cabinet to decide it's the planning
process responsibility to to work
through a compensation scheme Karla
homes are very aware and as council
mortars put I'm very sympathetic to the
issues that are being expressed by the
residents of Ludington there is a
compensation scheme set in law to which
this fits that will be agreed through a
next 106 and or Ness to seven eight with
a developer and that is signed by the
County Council in conjunction with us
any addition to that and the additional
need or compensation need will again be
dealt with through an S 106 right less -
it was - seven eight that it's something
that we can explore Giroux the planning
process and I understand is being
explored through the planning process
but at this point I think it's the wrong
thing for us now to sign off on
exploring that further when work is
already being done and will be wrapped
up within any final plan formation that
may or may not be granted and if that is
the case I'd like to know what timescale
is on that and when that will be
reported back because I think not to put
a timescale on that would not be would
not be wise in terms of that councilor
Pemberton then councillor riches
I think because of some recent changes
so I'm gonna be taking over the
chairmanship of that group that's is
that it would but we're going to be at
least both involved in it I think
probably need to get an update from Neil
Hempstead before we could give you
anything around timescales I think the
only other thing to say is that the
steering group is a mechanism and here's
what's been said I'm not convinced that
this is the right route for this at this
juncture but it it's not something that
the steering group now would not be
aware of and you guys have and will
continue to contribute as the relevant
board members so then that might be a
way for us to keep a breast of it um
it's not washing hands it's keeping it
but without you know we're not
necessarily the lead in this but at
least keeping a weather eye on it and
engaging with the county council through
the steering group may be able to so the
steering group to large degree has run
its course now I believe because we're
expecting a planning application to be
submitted imminent the whole purpose of
that steering group was to get us to
that at that point once the planning
application is in it's it's now down to
the time timewise it's down to the the
full extent of the the planning laws so
I think there's at 12 weeks for a major
or is it 16 clawed 16 because of the
significance of this it's likely to be a
little bit longer than maybe some
extensions the reality is it's now down
to that planning process so we can't
really tell a timescale but it is as you
well know from returning steering groups
and attending these meetings it is very
much at the forefront of people's minds
Neil Hempstead as one we've also got a
bear in mind that if we insist through
that process that Carter put aside a
part of X million for compensation that
ax men in comes across it comes off the
committed sound to
other infrastructure that this district
is desperate for so it there is a
balancing act to be had once I'm not
suggesting that we shouldn't be
compensating because as I said before
there is a very clear legal process for
that compensation and it will we do in
certain cases we do have to balance that
with the requirement for other
infrastructure as a result of this
development I entirely accept those
points I think councillor Richards is
being very optimistic on the timescale
the detailed planning application it's
not yet in the indications that have
been given to me is that this is likely
to be and it has been indicated that
this may be deferred until after the
election because it's such a contentious
item no that's for a decision for
decision chairman if the committee if
the cabinet was used to refer to the
steering committee and the steering
committee to report back to the cabinet
then so be it that would be one possible
way forward and I would be happy to
forward the outlines and my suggestion
onto to the steering committee one final
word chairman in our overseas I asked
members of the cabinet to think what if
I found ourselves serving myself in this
position if I'd bought the house in good
faith suddenly sitting there to discover
the proposal that might not be completed
and compensated for was not to me for
four years ahead it would be years
before I got compensation and I suddenly
find that I had to move and then my
house had taken a major hit on its value
because of this proposal how would I
feel if people were turning around to me
and saying I'm sorry to have it's
nothing to do with me I think if it
happened to you you would not be happy
that the campus German so I hope we'll
take that on board when we address this
thank you yep I understand the concerns
and the concerns are very real it
appears to me from what councillor
Richard has said there is actually a
process already in play
that could actually look at these issues
in parallel with that we have the County
Council that is actually looking at
issues and not only that the County
Council is the responsible body so I
think at the very least we should wait
to see what comes out of the process and
the County Council before making any
decision on what we should do and I
gather mr. Baxter wishes to speak on
this you have three minutes mr. Baxter
Thank You mr. chairman and fellow
councillors and all I wish to say
primarily is to provide if if you like a
personal view of the context of the
situation from my point of view
therefore last week on a lovely day I
was on rubbish standing and then walking
and across the meadow close to San Jose
very very peaceful blue sky and lovely
trees and some beautiful houses and and
then of course I saw this incredible
20-foot high approximately scaffold
which I'm saw you've seen in the
newspapers and then balloons right
across the meadow which is as you know
is a red area anyway all this provided a
realization to me for the first time of
the realities of the most probable
proposal that will eventually surface
somebody came up to me and said do you
know my house which is just over there
is only 20 meters from the highest point
of the road the road bridge that's
crossing over and my bedroom window
books directly on that section and I
thought then this is such a violation of
the environment and of personal liberty
I was appalled my worry about
unconcerned and primarily of all this is
that it's fine to talk about
compensation of monetary compensation
yes but why get to that state in the
first place we have our sense of
responsibility is hypotheticals so often
we just pay lip service as councils and
I'm talking January now towards what
should or should not be done we don't
actually feel our values here and we
don't activate our ethical values in
real life that is my prime concern and
it's why can proposals like this that
alter the surface and then caused
incredible consternation all around what
can we do well we weaken 30 seconds per
seconds what we can do is activate our
own values and reflect and then do
something that is constructive for the
community at large not just for the
administration's wherever they may be
thank you
at the moment a plumbing application has
not been submitted there will be a
planning process to go through as you
said there are issues it will actually
need to be considered as that planning
process unfolds so an awful lot of this
at the moment I think he's slightly
hypothetical nevertheless coming back to
the notice of motion given what I said
earlier that there is a process in place
through the steering group there is
things taking place at County Council I
think it is probably highly appropriate
for us to wait and see what the outcomes
of those are what in that case given
that councillor Moss said most of the
other issues were not of great
significance sorry my apologies
councillor Moore's nevertheless I have
to say in that case at this point in
time I will be very tempted to reject
the motion what are the views of cabinet
Richards and say just on that the first
point of what you said I will sit and
wait and see and whilst what you've set
up to that point
I completely agree with I don't think we
are going to sit and wait and see the
fact is we have a seat at the table
through the planning process through the
steering groups it's not just a question
of sitting and waiting
we are influencing that decision through
planning through the steering groups
we've got set up we've been doing that
for well over a year so once this is all
very nice coming forward now it's
already been viewed considered and put
forward or certainly the wheels are in
motion so we'll continue to do that and
on that basis I propose that we do
reject the motion
as you suggested I stand corrected
councillor Richards and their active
participation I'm sure has been real
boss camp slogan we have a proposal in
the second all those in favor
thank you
so the notice of motion is rejected
item seven
item 6 so it is 6
yes Ludington village design statement
mr. Weber believe you have a few words
first
yeah thank Thank You chairman first
before you start the debates on this
side sir if I could take members to page
76 item 2 there are some dates changes
that I need to make you aware of so
we've got some consistency in the report
in two point one way says the minutes
and Reddington parish council meeting
Harold on the trip of the 20th of
February 18 in option 1 to endorse the
VDS this is under 3.1 it should be 2018
not 17 option 2 should be 2018 and not
17 and option 3 should be 2018 and not
17 thank you
Thank You mr. Webb Chancellor Pemberton
do you wish to speak to this thank you
just very briefly chairman there's
there's been leaving aside some minor
typos and we're all human including our
officers and our cabinet members really
just would like to recommend a cabinet
to turn it's mine to page 75 and the
recommendations that the Ludington
village design statement 2018 we adopted
as a local information source it's it's
a good piece of work done by some a good
team of volunteers in the in the local
in in Ludington supported by officers
and this is a really useful source
material in determining applications in
the future through the core strategy and
I recommend it wholeheartedly Thank You
councillor Pemberton councillor bonds
thank you just to add to that I would
also take the opportunity to thank all
those involved with whether they've
undertaken to produce that excellent
document
yes Thank You mr. chairman this is a
second our missus come to the cabinet
the first time I couldn't approve it
because it did include parts of the
Paris that weren't part of the parish
for some particular reason which
canceled the gem and then when he used
that included they were very happy with
the presentation that's before you today
and help you we will like the portfolio
support it
Thank You councillor Barnes and I think
it is right what councillor Phil will
said that the amount of work that goes
into these is substantial I would like
to congratulate everyone on completing
it we must thank the District Council
also for allowing their I boards and
various things that some of the officers
have done for the demonstrations at the
village all because without them they
would have sort of just had them on the
floor thank you for that councillor
bonds agree
councillor Pemberton thank you Thank You
chairman and once again a pleasure
enjoying the cabinet's attention to the
recommendation at the head of page 79
that at this cabinet adopts the Aston
canto Parrish plan as a material
consideration once again awful lot of
work being done by the local community
and bringing this plan together and we
should record our thanks to them for for
the work that they've undertaken
supported again by officers to bring
together a plan that we can usefully use
and support used to support the core
strategy locally in Aston camera and I
seek support from the cabinet for the
recommendation thank you yeah once again
we congratulate the people for all the
effort protein is everyone in agreement
with a recommendation on page 79 plan
councillor Pemberton yet again I'm gonna
hat-trick now a chairman and once again
I think you know this is a good piece of
work in its entirety plan again just
drawing members attention to the
recommendation on page 85 but the perish
plan be adopted as a material
consideration and once again that we
should record our thanks to the army of
volunteers in Kinnison who've helped put
this plan together supported a Blee by
our officers in John Kerr Foods team so
once again short and sweet and
recommendation as per page 85 or so in
terms of the recommendation on page 85
is that acceptable to cabinet members
great thank you
so item 9 review of stratford-on-avon
district housing strategy not only
hat-trick councillor Pemberton but
fourth
Thank You chairman just trying to get to
the relevant part and try to save paper
here and get to the relevant part so the
recommendation is that the report be
noted and that the revised milestones in
the in the Housing Strategy be endorsed
I think really it's a case of members
will have had the opportunity to take a
look at the strategy and are there any
questions any observations before we
debate further and look at the
recommendation I see councillor Morse
councillor
there are three points I wanted to raise
on the commentary chairman page 91
number nine housing support nine point
two examined feasibility by June 2019 of
providing additional supported housing
to reduce the use of bed and breakfast
accommodation Chairman we all know that
the piece of these problems is in winter
especially for the homeless when we have
cold-weather support that we have to
provide in those people quite often go
into bed and breakfast it seems to me
that June 2019 will be after the next
winter and it's disappointing that it's
gonna take so long I wondered if it was
possibly look at that more quickly so
that by the time next winter comes we've
done this work and we've got the extra
accommodation in hand otherwise chairman
were accepting that we're gonna have to
put people into bed and breakfast again
next winter on point 12 over page don't
sorry if you wish to respond to that
point please do take them in order
I think cancer I think forecastle nose I
think head of service robbed weeks may I
have a comment for you
I take councillor mosses point but I
wouldn't want to leave the impression
that the the the action that the council
is in active during the winter months
with respect to those people that have
come to us for for assistance we have a
severe weather protocol that kicks in
and we have very vigorous with that and
in fact last winter as you know it was
prolonged winter and we went to great
lengths to to help people that needed
that and as of today I think we're down
to about three rough sleepers in the
district although I take the point that
you're not exactly referring very prone
to rough sleepers but clearly during the
bad weather they are the most vulnerable
of our clients this piece of work
chairman is aimed at the other customers
those other clients that we have that
aren't as exposed as rough sleepers
these are people that are struggling
under a roof at the moment but do not
have the help to maintain an tenancy
perhaps for health issues drug and
alcohol abuse issues addiction issues of
any kind really mental health so it
isn't simply a case of throwing money at
it it's a piece of work that we we are
we have started and we work with
partners at the moment to provide this
support we recognize the need to move
forward with it but the reason for the
date being set is firstly recognizing
the Star Chamber process where the
budgets are assessed budgets are then
issued in April and then hopefully by
June we are able to to initiate
something that will make a difference
and behind this these words chairman
you'll be aware that the council is
considering another piece on these local
housing company we're also committed to
returning back to cabinet by September
October this year with a report on how
we establish a purpose-built supported
unit so the date is trying to
synchronize as many other related things
as possible without handicapping the
council
of course you wish response mr. Richards
he's taken everything out Thank You
chairman I mean it is the brutal truth
of the matter that you know despite our
best efforts and despite a call for
science and despite research it is
proven hugely difficult to bring forward
appropriate sites and sites do have to
be appropriate in all aspects if they're
going to work effectively as sites for
gypsy and traveler communities it it it
is difficult to see at this juncture
what else we were able to do we can't
just either produce sites because as I
say it's not a case of just having a
piece of land it's a piece of land in in
in and around the right place where the
where the where can be integration with
the set
community where there's access to
facilities schools and medical
facilities so I think you know the the
comment tree made there is really just
shortened to the point it is not
something that is falling off of our
radar it is something that is continuing
our officers and I wish we could bring
forward a little more positive but we
keep trying hard of people bringing
forward I think most makes a valid point
but I go back to we can only do what we
can do and you know we would if we are
then faced with the planning is better
we're going to have to demonstrate what
we've tried to do I think I would agree
with you councilor Pemberton that
councillor Morse has made a valid point
make this is uncomfortable just saying
it's proven difficult to engage
I think I think I think councillor
Morris he shoots he scores he's got his
third valid point I would go on to say
however it's not just as bald as it is
proving difficult it is more than
proving difficult we we have tried to
engage to try and do some work in this
area we have however there are there's
an alternative approach being adopted in
in another part of the county and we're
looking to try and see if we can
replicate some of the success from that
approach with with Nuneaton trust and so
we we're making the observation I think
these things it's a commentary on where
we're at it is not saying we're not
doing anything we are actively looking
at a different protocol to see if we can
bring that into play to be more
effective in helping discharge
absolutely I think all of us around the
table recognize the issues around
delayed discharge around inappropriate
discharge around unsupported discharge
and we are our officers are being active
in trying to find a solution to that and
actually to bring the solution to the
NHS itself in real terms to try and make
it as easy as possible for them to
actually engage with us and I do expect
that we'll be able to bring some some
further positive news on that in the
not-too-distant so recommendations on
page 89 the report be noted and the
revised milestones in the review of
Housing Strategy 2015 2:20 as I favoured
2018 they endorsed thank you
item 10 co-op site primary square still
a counselor car game thank you thank you
chairman this has been rolling on for a
little while now the community have
obviously want some movement on this
particular site and it was in the March
cabinet that a timetable was put forward
to the coop now we are aware that in
actual fact the coop are currently
adhering to that timetable the
pre-application correctly from right has
been submitted and they are engaging
with us in the planning process it may
not be what the community would like and
I do accept the frustrations of the
community there but at this moment I
don't feel that we have any option of
the van accepting this report
it's noting this report and then my
suggestion is that unless there is
substantial movement by September then
we would go back to examining them in a
robust manner because obviously we have
got concerns about what they can put on
that particular site what would go on
that site is applying issue and that
will have to be go through the normal
planning process but at this moment
that's that see anything I can suggest I
get very agitated because over the
period that I've been arguing and
fighting them this side I've gone from
being a member of the work force
becoming a retiree then an old-age
pensioner are now a very old age
pensioner and we're still talking about
this site you know it's a long way what
did worry me in this report because I
actually do believe that the offices and
look and the cabinet members involved
are really are doing their best in this
area because I've had the advantage of
seeing it not treated with the respect
it should have been treated but I do
feel that has now
changed and people are taking a very
different view but the thing that I got
a bit worried but in fact you've
reassured me in what you said was the
risk that the coop will not uphold their
part of the agreement also remains and
that six point one but having said now
if it gets to September and nothing's
going to happen I I feel happier about
that that that's been said and really
all I can do is thank people for the
effort that they're being that is now
being made you know and as I said I've
got the advantage of being able to
compete comparisons and I do feel that
people are sincere over this now thank
you thank you and my only response is
you're just an old-age pensioner Thank
You councillor I'd like I can assure you
we are taking this seriously and yes
regardless of what happened before we
are now taking this very seriously so
the recommendation on page 109 that the
progress set out in the report is noted
agreed thank you to me eleven rail
shuttles rail shuttle study councillor
Cargill again thank you
this follows on from the work that's
been done by cancer Richards in this
role prior to this obviously this is a
high-level study and the idea is higher
level there's been a bit of criticism in
as much as perhaps some of the data is
out to date but it is indicative of what
is possible and potential for this for
this area
I think it's self-evident that's an
expensive scheme whichever wait the
route we go however there are benefits
and such like the option for cabinet
today I would wreck
and is that we accept the report to
recommend that the rarity shuttle study
is presented received by the District
Council as a technical report Thank You
councillor Cotterill
thank the cabinet for agreeing to the
study and the work that's been done by
the officers and others as far as I can
see
funnily enough in this rapid observer it
said buffers up in other words the law
is there but the cost appears to be too
great at this very moment depending on
the Cyprus shuffle depending on whether
we have to have level crossing where
they have to have a bridge but there is
great demand for it the other thing that
the not a criticism but the situation
was that they didn't look at the whole
area in the respect of me and Vale it
was just a few houses on the garden city
which has to be included in the motion I
couldn't include the whole area but as
you know a lot of the people in the new
part of me and Vale and virtually 6000
how's it going
six thousand houses going up in which
Ivan me and bow and possibly even to an
hour thousand on the airfield I think
you will see by the report that if the
numbers go up then it may be viable so
we need to keep it open we would like to
keep save the green bang because that's
what Tom's telling to do so that we can
cycle to the Train 40% of the people
actually now either cycle one way or the
other way off the train which he's got
remarkable feat fairly but as you can
see even though the continent if they do
even more but what I'm saying is I'm
very pleased that we're moving forward
on this hope that we will go for options
too and the court happy to answer any
sort of questions but we must thank you
for moving this way and we listen to
what Tom's got to say yes he's trying to
save the green mate just like me we
don't want the railway through Stratford
but we wanted these to the where the
heavies are to save the congestion on
the B for six feet ooh and they say
Tom's against the road got the rail
don't need the road but I'll leave it to
you come back to me in a minute thank
you for your comments mr. Baxter do you
wish to speak now three minutes I get
again Thank You Erin yes I mean just a
couple of points really it's interesting
there Arup actually in their report they
mention the possible in fact probable
impact environmentally of the link from
Long Marston
- honey born and one of these solutions
that they put forward is flexible buses
that is to say a flexible minibus
service a la Kent where a couple of
companies down there have been running
very successfully buses which covered a
wide a number of areas to start towards
the destination of the station so there
are ways around this but I do support a
link form Long Marston - honey born
whether it's got to be rare or not is a
bit of problematic for one big reason
there are many elephants in the room
Chilton Great Western just a name a
couple of them because they have both
said oh yes we we like this proposal
because
Ling brings forward the solution for our
point of view commercially to link to
strap it on even so I think if we are
thinking in planning terms we need to
have a bit of a sense of the long view
if it goes ahead then we could have to
be very sensitive about any possible
implications northbound to
stratford-on-avon because the
urbanization for that whole part of
South Warren so that would then occur
would be mer menses it's already getting
bad enough why
for one big reason severally well a few
years ago now I think it was five maybe
seven years ago as a council we gave in
to the guidelines of the government at
that time we rolled over and we said yes
yes whatever you want and we've been
hoist with our own petard as a result so
there we are
yes to the link to honey born but it's
the means that I'm against it's query
phase strongly and I would alert all of
us to any possible development to
linking northbound to Stratford thank
you very much thank you just to clarify
we are you saying that we should have a
rail link it from a long last and to
Stratford no definitely not
so the question I would ask then is
obviously we have the the 4,300 road
which is so would you agree that perhaps
either have traffic on the road or a
railing helicopter yes
there's nothing nothing stopping a very
good a service frequently it can be done
it's we just don't conceive and things
like that
and there's no reason why people can't
become a lot more careful about how
frequently and when they use their cars
how many essential journeys from low
Marston to Stratford by Road are
undertaken I would think a much less
than we might envisage labonz our
friends in the respect of saving the
Greenway I have spoken at which Agron
and as far as they're concerned
dorsen and the pep worth and through to
only born is not acceptable for a bush
there is a small bus goes for some
people on the 742 now from me and Bale
and it's quite often can't get through
to the train there is a parking problem
there and as far as I'm concerned the
solution is to extend that line a little
and we don't want it disrupted but
unfortunately if you know Dorson turn or
peb worth or through Long Marston and I
think your cancer brain is looking but
the county councillor for that area
whatever his name is to support me on
that
okay thank you
so counselor car dealer you are saying
that we should accept recommendation one
the cabinet receives the study as a
technical report correct I think so the
cabinet receives us to be a technical
report thank you so my personal view on
this is this isn't a particularly good
report for me it feels like an answers
been decided upon and then we've looked
for the reasons to come to that answer
there is so much more that needs to be
done in terms of research understanding
of the problem we're going to have and
and frankly have now at long last and
Millvale
low Quentin that entire surrounding area
and the Camden Road is already near as
damn it at capacity we're gonna
introduce three and a half thousand
homes at Long Martin me on Vale are
already expanding their side I
understand they've got somewhere around
about 3,000 homes there and you adding
codec Sims in which Haven and you've got
the better part 10,000 homes all of what
you're going to need to get to either
Birmingham or down to London this does
not go far enough this doesn't put
consideration to that and should do so
in my view we should be rejecting this
sending it back and having it done
properly by our up before we accept it
as a as a piece of paperwork that will
indicate how we move forward there is so
much more that needs to be done I'll
give you one example is the cost of a
bridge along Station Road there's no
reason to put a bridge on that road
whilst guidance suggests that we should
have bridges I don't see why we can't
use the existing track and have a rail
crossing along that road that I ask that
question when we have this presented to
us some time ago and so on no one does
that anymore
I saw three at the weekend while I was
in Cambridge so they are there we need
to lobby the right people to get those
put there that reduces the cost
significantly but this is something
that's arrived at an answer that seems
to have been predetermined there is so
much more work that needs to be done
needs to be rejected in my mind and a
proper report done and certainly some
indication as to how we're going to
transport we as a council are going to
be able to cope with transporting the
residents that are going to be at me on
Vale at long last on our code exams
councillor Richards this study seems to
have focused almost predominantly on
heavy rail and what you're suggesting is
there might be a wider range of possible
solutions so is that something that we
should actually look up separately
rather than from this I think this all
feeds into it some of the works been
done here but not all of it not enough
of it so once this could inform
something going forward at the moment if
we accept this we're accepting that this
is right I don't think this is right I
don't think works that I don't think
sufficient work has been done to
determine whether this is or isn't right
we have a duty of care to our resins we
have to make sure they can get around on
our networks whether that be on the road
whether that be by train I don't think
this has gone far enough
to consider the train impact they didn't
consider the possibility of seven
thousand houses there but it wasn't in
the report we're talking in the first
initial thing thank you
I think the recommendation is not the
report is accepted but the report is
received and there is quite a lot of
difference between the two perhaps you
explain to me what differences accepting
the report is accepting what is written
in it receiving a report is is having
the report receiving one unchallenged in
my mind is accepting it to be correct
this one isn't correct I won't be voting
to accept this or to receive it it says
move forward so if we look at paragraph
4.1 of the report as the officer has
written the report it sets out three
separate options so we've got one that
the report be received secondly that the
report be received and that some more
work be done and then option three that
the report is not quote accepted and it
appears to me although the office can
probably speak for himself that the
recommendation seems to me to follow
option to simply because it's both
receiving the report and then doing some
more work but I'm happy to be corrected
after the distinction between receiving
report and accepting it that seems to be
how option one and option three have
been phrased one is receive and the
other is not accept and again I'm
interpreting what councillor Richards
has said he's presumably as suggesting
option 3 okay from a personal
perspective I was happy just to accept
this report not saying we wouldn't be
going to do any more work on this
the second option in fact if you notice
on that says on 5.1 definitely need a
notice notice the findings of the study
is keen to engage industry stakeholders
in case investigate the matter further
including more feasible and viable
alternatives so I was taking that
particular point aboard
does that not fit accept other
alternatives can be looked at but I
think that's the next step we haven't I
don't in my mind Arup have not completed
the work they
should have been completing on this rail
study this report does not go into
enough data and enough consideration the
exact impacts what's possible when it
comes to rail it simply is not up to
standard as a business person if I was
paying someone to produce a report this
would be thrown back on the made me to
be table dirt properly because this is
just insufficient inadequate you
actually said to me previously as well
comes to the kettle Thank You mr.
chairman
it seems to me but actually you could
you can support both one and three
options I've got two points to make my
way in that you can receive it because
it's in your hands but actually reject
it because it's not up to speed which i
think is what counts of Richard's point
is made but my more fundamental point
which I might raise is it talks about
heavy rail and it talks about various
different types of carriageway some of
which are very familiar and the picture
on one of the page it is of the sort of
commercial about it was any
consideration came in the instruction to
Arab to look outside heavy rail
solutions was any suggestion made I mean
as you may now have been back before to
Dublin quite a lot recently and there
they have a huge into tramway system
that runs on runs on light tracks was in
the terms of reference were required to
look outside the box and have purely
heavy rail solutions if they weren't I
think it may be appropriate to bring mr.
Kerr for dinner at this point Thank You
chair and actually I was just concurring
counsel kettle there to be fair to Arab
they've done what we asked them to do in
their brief it was a very high-level
brief for not an awful lot of money so
we've got or be painful now the question
is then is actually having done that
piece of work do we want to do something
much bigger which i think is the point
castle Richards is alluding to but I
think with respect I think that's a
slightly separate point so our Arab
we've done the work we did request
antutu and that is why the
recommendation on page 1 1 3 does follow
option 2 which is to receive the study
and then allow officers to
you start to start to explore that
further work okay thank you mr. Chaffetz
so the reality from what you're saying
is that our rope of doom what we ask
them to do however it may well be that
there are more questions that need to be
answered which picks up councillor
Richards point so that work does not
necessarily need to be done by arif does
it that will be a completely separate
piece of work at a very high level did
they at any stage so do you want to look
at anything other than heavy rail and
did we say no the brief was primarily to
look at the reinstating derail link or
name freight only branch so it did start
to look at other options as alternatives
but the focus was heavy round on the
existing fragrant organ councillor
Barnes then councillor Pemberton I think
it's appropriate to consider why this
report ever came about and it was in
response to a notice of motion to
actually have a study to explore the
possibility of providing a rail study
service that was a notion of no notice
of motion to his council and that is
what has been responded to and that is
why the report says what it is and so I
think we have got what was requested
following the notice of motion from
Council Barnes seconded by Councillor
Wojtek councillor Barnes in councilor
but yes miss jeren my motion has been
looked at I appreciate that and I did it
because of the Garden City situation is
that in the report there was nothing
there about all the other thousands of
houses more houses than in the Garden
City going up in that area and there
which able which is an important factor
which counts the riches it brought up
this is simple as that the thing is a
lot wider than it is I think to be fair
council dances mentioned in here of the
census in 2021 looking at travel pattern
catalog it made a point I was gonna make
so in other words this report may well
of dunwood it was asked but that does
not mean there is not more work than
he's doing on a much wider set of issues
so with that in mind obviously we have a
report later on agenda in relation to
the out term for 2017-18 we potentially
earmark some funding from that I am well
aware of the need that if we wanted to
do a study we would need more funding so
I have a proposal from councilor Cargill
that we go for option one to recommend
that the rail shuttle study is presented
he's received by the district council is
a technical report do I happen Richard I
understood we were the suggestion was it
would be option to say that further work
would be undertaken are we just
receiving because I will be voting
against that if it's just receiving is
option two
just it's option one option two or
option three everyone receives up from
two receives and further work option
three rejects cancer organ as I
understand it
councillor Cargill is recommending that
the cabinet receives the study as a
technical report full stop and I'm quite
happy to second that thank you this is
such an important matter there is not
only the rail study but there's the
whole question of the road study the B
four six three two and it's already
already been mentioned about how many
houses are eventually going to appear in
that whole area so there's still massive
work to be done and I think it would be
wrong of us just to accept this report
without saying that there must be
further work done and it should also
include a road study as well in much
more detail certainly what was in my
mind was we accept this report and then
we move on because there's no doubt
about it that more work needs doing
that work has to be done that's why we
want option two and not only that
exactly what he said about the roads
that he's extremely relevant so there is
a big piece of work that still needs to
be done now one of the problems I have
with option two it still seems to focus
on heavy rails for me and yet we want
something much wider than that
councillor Richard we add an additional
option and word it now yes it is through
you what reports and what work there is
going to be done on
the garden village and infrastructure
for that that is already in the system
before we jump into asking for more
stuff councillor kettle CA mr. chair if
you read options one option two option 2
incorporates the entirety of option one
anyway in fact it is identical wording
until the end of the technical report
and then it continues that officers
going to be instructed to carry out
further work so actually councillor
Cargill and councillor organs proposal
is already in - so if you're proposing
to move forward with work it seems
strange to reject option 2 if you're
saying we're going to carry out further
work anyway so it seems to me the
logical one is accept compliment and
mrs. Cargill and proposal but as in the
wording in - rather than limiting it to
one you've got the best of both worlds
your meeting council houses and council
Richard's concerns whilst running with
number one at the same time in sorry in
that case should we accept both
recommendations okay do I have a
proposal to seconder all those in favor
of accepting both recommendations that's
one - is that one too
against weekly on any abstaining because
I'm Harley unhappy with a report that is
being received made that exceedingly
clear councillor Richards we had got it
eased in relief we would never bro
exemption of contract standing orders
councillor Richards thank chair this
should be a lot easier than last one so
I'm sure you can I can regret that so as
you all well know we're anniversa
Council and what we're looking here to
do here is simply to align two contracts
so there are n dates are the same
existing contract with Lincolnshire
County Council for the call center
element of the service expires in March
2019 with the contract with watch County
Council and the providers expiring on
29th of May we're simply trying to bring
those into line Thank You chairman it
does seem eminently sensible to me as
well all those in favor a great good
right item 13 renewal of the Business
Improvement District in Stratford
councillor house thank you very much mr.
chairman I will keep this fairly brief
as the paper explains things quite
adequately what this is all about it is
about the Business Improvement District
the bid which is a legally prescribed
scheme where businesses within a
precisely defined geographical
area found local service improvements to
enhance their trading environment and in
fact you will see a map of the area in
the appendix in order for the bid to
establish itself there has to be a
ballot of the propria in the defined
area and it has to meet certain criteria
which it has already done so in the past
since 2009 when it was first started it
ran successfully and that in 2013 it
confirmed the support for bid - which
started in April 2014 and it's due to
the end due to end on the 31st of March
2019 which is the reason why it is
before us now because there has to be a
new ballot over the past five years
Stratfor would have played a key role in
developing a program of festivals events
and street entertainment which many of
us have partake in and which have been
immensely successful in addition to that
the bid have been working closely with
Shakespeare England the destination
management organization so that they can
attract more business to the town and to
improve the take that we get from the
tourists who come here and it's
currently worth I think some I read of
2.1 million pounds so the bid renewal
strap forward wrote to the council on
the 11th of May giving us formal notice
of the forthcoming him ballot the
movement going forward is assessed at
Appendix 1 and it sets out the timetable
of the key activities that are necessary
leading up to the ballot result which
will happen on the 28th of September
2018 in terms of the cost this is borne
by the businesses who pay a levy the
current levy being proposed is one point
four seven percent of their annual and
NDR and this is due to rise one point
four nine percent in year two 2020 to
2021 the bid have produced a business
plan which
I have to admit I haven't seen in detail
yet due to being away but they will
carry on doing much of the work that
they have already been doing in the past
promoting the area hosting town hosts
and so on and so forth and adding things
like the big cast game bid card scheme
to give discounts to people in the area
so the options available to the cabinet
are to vote yes just before I cover that
as a result of the number of properties
you don't within the proposed bid area
the council will have a number of votes
in the ballot so we like all the other
businesses do contribute to the to the
bid the council needs to identify an
appropriate office to complete the bid
ballot papers on behalf of the authority
there is a risk that if we don't go
ahead with recommending recommend a
mission that this is approved on item
77.4 we thought it says in summary there
are advantages and disadvantages but on
balance positive support for a renewed
bid would seem to be the best option for
the council so mr. Chairman I would
refer you back to the recommendations on
the facing page which I don't propose to
read out but they're numbered 1 2 & 3 in
heavy black writing thank you Thank You
councillor house this looks pretty
straightforward any discussion
councillor kettle but I think this is
next scheme will they voted as they have
towards it we look forward to this
council supporting it I do have to
question why given there are 300 schemes
set out on paragraph 1.4
that we're not promoting similar schemes
in other market towns within the
district particularly those towns
further from Stratford perhaps one might
say east of the m-40 so sow them or trip
stone which is quite a long way from I
perhaps
and I recommend that we should consider
this a powerful council council houses
remit going forward rather than just
limit it this one has to be limited to
Stratford I understand that it is
limited to strap though well one could
rollout of similar type scheme in other
market towns in the district I think
from a viability point of view that
might prove quite difficult if I could
just refer to Dave web for the moment to
give you a more positive answer mr. Webb
chairman council has is right there are
no Business Improvement Districts in the
rest in the rest of Stratford history
but what we have done in the past we've
invested an awful lot of money in
Southam in chip stone and in Ulster
supporting businesses in all of those
places and that investments has gone on
for quite a number of years so there has
we haven't actually put everything into
Stratford at the expense of other areas
they've all benefited from money that
the councillors had a made available
thank you
oh sorry recommendations on page 121
these acceptable a grade good thank you
Thank You mr. chairman so moving on item
14 counselor organ Thank You chairman
the local parish council wish to
introduce a holistic scheme of charges
for the car parks in Henley and Arden in
order to support the viability of the
town center to achieve this they wish to
lease Prince Harry Road car park from
the district council in order that it
can be operated in concert with their
northern car park and the Croft car park
their business plan is attached as
Appendix 2 to the report
Prince Harry car park was transferred to
Stratford District Council from Bloor
homes in 1990 it has space for about 50
vehicles and a restrictive covenant that
it is used as a public car park and will
be kept in a good state of repair and
condition the council do not levy
parking charges for the use of this car
park and have liability for the
maintenance costs the options available
to the council are to grant a lease to
refused to grant a lease or to request
further information the recommendation
is to agree a full repairing lease with
the local parish council and for the
lease to include some additional
obligations for example six free spaces
for the medical center and free parking
for the associated medical uses for
example mobile screening vehicles Thank
You councillor well Thank You chairman I
support very much what councilor organ
has just said regarding the parking
issue within Henley and Arden it's been
a long-term aim of the parish council to
try and resolve such a situation by
trying to move certain car owners ie
workers that come in to Henley
to the northern carpark to ensure the
takapa switcher far more central can be
utilized those people visiting only for
other shopping or indeed just a business
arrangement so I do like to support I
would request on the recommendation
bearing in mind in 0.1 point one for
when it talks about the detailed
additional obligations
the details are agreed with the relevant
portfolio holders and the ward member I
request that was initially and that was
attached to the recommendation itself to
ensure I'd get involved Laconia this
clarification council organ I'm taking
them as you were saying there are six
free spaces that the the council local
council will be charging for parking in
this location one assumed so but it is
of course it would be in the gift of the
parish council according to how they
wish to run their car parks I believe it
is their intention to have a child
charging schedule but it is within their
responsibility and liability and I would
not like to presume that I know what the
future uses for that car park might be
Thank You Sherman I think you'd be
viewed as short term car park between
nine and six pm those details needed to
work out but it's important that those
six car parking spaces have been
referred to they're not the staff there
are actually four patients actually
visiting the Medical Center because I
have been issues in the past whereby so
elderly people have to visit public how
to walk about a quarter of a mile
further down the road says to protect
that that they remain free
coupled with advises all the health
services that do come in to use a car
park like we've had the breast skin and
the screening operation so anything like
that would be free the kettle
public concern about charging for I
would just raise the point is six
sufficient for a lot of small settlement
surgery given that people do need to
queue up for those nursing services
Pharma and pharmacy services as well as
and should we be sure we can question
whether the Tanners is the right number
I'm sorry six is the right number and
this is a surgery happy with that
counselor Pemberton then Council
Chairman I think we I think that the the
people know best is Henry and Beaudesert
Parish care so I think we can't start
setting guessing that this seems an
enema eminently sensible thing to do and
I'm suggest we move to the
recommendation Thank You chairman just
to reply to councilor kettles query
there are car parking spaces within the
medical center anyway research has
already been done in the past to
establish six is the right amount of car
parking spaces and indeed that is
working very very well okay so shall we
move to the recommendation with the
addition of counselor Sarah was
suggestion all those in favor the grade
good item 15 counselor organ Thank You
chairman this is the out turn position
for the prudential indicators for the
year 1718 the key aim of these
indicators is is to ensure that capital
investment plans of local authorities
are affordable prudent and sustainable
the calculation the calculation of the
potential indicators is mandatory and
within the five-year plan the council
has no plans to borrow to fund any
capital projects this means there are no
areas of concern to report from the
prudential indicators and the
recommendation is that the report is
received any comments
so agreed that the report has received a
grade thing it some sixteen councillor
organ thank you chairman the capital
expenditure budgeted for 1718 was 4.3
million and actual expenditure amounted
to 1.4 million as detailed in Appendix 1
paragraph 2 details the various under
spends and slippage requests which are
tabled in appendix 3 and the total
slippage request is 2.6 million appendix
to list the total section 106 fund
recommendation is to slip into 18 thank
you I'm just surprised by the
description of this has been a vital
element in the plan to reduce reliance
on bed-and-breakfast for accommodation
with the homeless we only nominate
people thank you
perhaps it would be appropriate for mr.
weeks to respond to this two weeks
chairman thank you when we when we
receive someone who claims to be
homeless then there are a number of
checks and assessments performed on the
individual and basically whether we
accept a duty or not and once we've
accepted a duty then they are placed in
temporary combination until such time as
they are able to bid for
in the same way as anybody else on the
register to bid for a property making
use of private sector properties which
this grant was initially targeted to do
is that vital element to try and get
people off the register whether they are
homeless or being be off the register
into a place that they could hopefully
call their own and continue to grow it
isn't the only tool that we use but what
we're struggling to use this one as
evidence in the report German but we
hope to be able to make much better use
of it going forward thank you
Thank You councillor Moore's come sir
organ and perhaps it might be
appropriate to amend the wording on the
top of page one four nine the second
line is to remove the word vital so it
says it is an element of the plan maybe
that would be more appropriate wording
with that the recommendation on page 147
is that acceptable and ease the removal
of the word vital acceptable thank you
item 17 council organ
thank you chairman the revenue out turn
is in line with monitoring forecasts and
shows a favorable variance the main
feature being the receipt of more than 1
million pound income over that budgeted
for and the significant areas are
detailed in Para 1 3 which is on page
165 continuing on 166 appendices 1 & 2
attached the report also detailed a
revenue out term position by service
area and category for the year 1718 the
main operational variances to budget are
detailed within the table on page 167
and 168 along with explanations for the
variances
which are in the comments columns
included within this table are the
requests for slippage which total
366,000
and these are further explained in
paragraph 1.8 one of the report in
addition to these requests the slippage
I would like to include slipping a
further one hundred and seven thousand
pounds in relation to transformation
from the underspend
of one hundred and fifty three thousand
in the corporate management executor
executive director service on page one
six seven this will change the slippage
figure on one six nine para one seven
one table to by adding a further one
hundred and seven thousand to a total of
four hundred and seventy three thousand
and ninety five pounds thus altering the
draft revenue reserve to nine million
four hundred and forty eight 108 I would
recommend that cabinet accepts the
recommendations on page 165
recommendations one and three and that
recommendation to the slippage figure of
three sixty six oh nine five is amended
to 473 as we discussed thank you find
the most this year
head of that figure which means that
come the end of next year if we don't
spend that two and a half million pounds
we will have reserves at 12 million
pounds am I right in thinking that
you've seen sir just a book loan I can't
focus maths absolutely if the council
expended 2.54 million that was provided
in the by counseling back on the in
April then yes then that would be the
position of course we've had a very
clear stare of your priorities in
relation to spending that money and
projects forward so I'd be surprised if
the 2.5 4 million was unspent at the end
of the year I have to say counselor
Morris there is a very clear steer on
getting things done so in that case if
we look at the recommendations on page
165 taking account of the amendment
proposed by the councilor organ are we
in favor a grade Oh issues arising from
overview overview and scrutiny committee
none part day on block items cabinet
work program that was circulated at the
beginning of the meeting
ladies policy advisory group minute on
page 179 and 80 stratford-on-avon
stratford-upon-avon markets forum
minutes on pages 181 184 of the
acceptable a great start time of
meetings
oh we experimented with this at 3:30 is
this time acceptable or do you want to
change it now so farewell German it's
great to have the meetings in the
afternoon but I think he might help
people's Diaries with any healing
commitments if we were able to start at
3 o'clock
Thank You chair I'd actually put a
contrary view this sort of 3:30 helps
every day and evening commitments
personally I'd shoot for 4:00 p.m. but I
can live with 3:30 and I think it starts
to be 3:00 p.m. for those of us who have
died commitments outside of this
building it starts to become you lose an
afternoon so I think there is a balance
the answer is us to be more efficient
and on that basis I should be more quiet
may I suggest 315 don't you don't even
go there
if council Plumpton was put for clock I
would support that because we just
assumed my day and my evening
commitments but 339 parish council
meetings sometimes monthly and if we go
first we know Cora class-five had a
quick meeting today if it extends
further it pushes the limits that I can
get to a parish council meeting which is
far and wide in my district so I
wouldn't except for a clock can I make a
suggestion that we run with 334 another
couple of meetings and then review is
unacceptable agreed thank you